GETTING CLOSER TO THAT.
ED HENRY, THANK YOU.
WHAT EXACTLY IS THE DEMOCRATIC
BORDER SECURITY PROPOSAL?
WE HAD SOME TIME TODAY SO WE
CHECKED IN AND A WORD NO, IT
WOULD NOT.
THE DEMOCRATIC BILL IN THE
SENATE THAT I WAS JUST TELLING
YOU ABOUT IT SIMPLY RESTORES
PREVIOUS FUNDING LEVELS FOR THE
BORDER PATROL AND OTHER EXISTING
PROGRAMS.
YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF WHEN
YOU CONSIDER THAT, WAS THE
BORDER SECURE IN DECEMBER BEFORE
THE SHUTDOWN?
NO, IT WASN'T AND THAT IS WHERE
WE WERE HAVING THIS DEBATE RIGHT
NOW.
HOW TO BE MORE SECURE AFTER A
BILL THAT DOESN'T CHANGE
ANYTHING PASSES?
IT WOULD BE MORE SECURE AND THAT
IS THE POINT OF THE LEGISLATION,
THE BROKEN STATUS QUO.
MEANWHILE IN THE HOUSE, WHEN
SECURITY COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
BENNIE THOMPSON SAYS, HE PLANS
TO INTRODUCE A BILL THAT
CONTAINS BILLIONS FOR BORDER
SECURITY BUT NOTHING FOR A
WHILE.
IT IS A BRAND-NEW IDEA HE IS
TELLING US.
HE SAID HE CAN SECURITY BORDER
WITH THE MARVELS OF TECHNOLOGY,
HE TOLD PBS THAT CUTTING EDGE
MACHINES CAN HELP US IDENTIFY
THOSE VULNERABILITIES ON THE
BORDER.
HIS PLANT EXPECTS ENTHUSIASM AND
SUPPORT ME CONGRESSMAN FROM TECH
LAND, NANCY PELOSI, HERE IS HER
MOST RECENT.
WATCH.
>> THE POSITIVE, TECHNOLOGICAL
WALL THAT CAN BE BUILT IS WHAT
WE SHOULD BE DOING.
TECHNOLOGY TO SCAN THE CARS
COMING THROUGH THE PORTS OF
ENTRY AND THAT IS TO DETECT GUN
GUNS, LIKE AN ELECTRONIC DOG.
IT CAN DETECT DRUGS, OTHER
CONTRABAND.
>> Tucker: IT IS LIKE AN
ELECTRIC DOG, THAT IS HILARIOUS.
WE LAUGHED ABOUT IT BEFORE BUT
IT IS ALSO PATRONIZING.
YOU HAVE TO BE TOTALLY IGNORANT
OF WHAT IS HAPPENING ON OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER TO BELIEVE THAT
MORE SURVEILLANCE IS GOING TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
WE HAVE AN AWFUL LOT OF
SURVEILLANCE TECHNOLOGY THERE
ALREADY, DRONES, CAMERAS,
SENSORS, RADARS, WE HAVE IT
THERE IN PART BECAUSE OF THE
BUSH ADMINISTRATION PUT IT
THERE.
THAT ADMINISTRATION SPENT MORE
THAN A BILLION DOLLARS ON THE
SECURE BORDER INITIATIVE
NETWORK.
THE TECHNOLOGY TO WATCH ABOUT 5I
THE TECHNOLOGY TO WATCH ABOUT 5E
THE TECHNOLOGY TO WATCH ABOUT 5S
THE TECHNOLOGY TO WATCH ABOUT 5O
THE TECHNOLOGY TO WATCH ABOUT 5F
THE TECHNOLOGY TO WATCH ABOUT 5R
THE TECHNOLOGY TO WATCH ABOUT 5S
THE TECHNOLOGY TO WATCH ABOUT 5U
THE TECHNOLOGY TO WATCH ABOUT 5H
THE TECHNOLOGY TO WATCH ABOUT 5R
THE TECHNOLOGY TO WATCH ABOUT 5N
THE TECHNOLOGY TO WATCH ABOUT 5B
THE TECHNOLOGY TO WATCH ABOUT 5R
THE TECHNOLOGY TO WATCH ABOUT 5E
THE TECHNOLOGY TO WATCH ABOUT 5.
THE NEED THOMPSON HIMSELF THAT
PROGRAM "GRAVE AND EXPENSIVE
DISAPPOINTMENT."
HE WAS RIGHT ABOUT THAT WHICH
CHANGED, DEMOCRATS NOW SUPPORT
THE DISAPPOINTMENT.
THEY SPECIALIZE IN A GREAT
DISAPPOINTMENT.
THEY'RE PUSHING ONE NOW.
AT THE SHORTSIGHTED, LEAVING THE
POLITICS ASIDE IT IS NOT A GOOD
IDEA BECAUSE OUR SOUTHERN BORDER
IS ONE OF AMERICA'S MOST
INTEREST VULNERABILITIES.
IT IS NOT A TALKING POINT, IT IS
LITERALLY TRUE AND HERE'S WHY.
AS OF TONIGHT MEXICO IS AN
ATTACHED COUNTRY, WILL REMAIN
THAT?
MAYBE NOT.
MEXICO IS A DEEPLY UNSTABLE
PLACE, NOT AN ATTACK ON THE
MEXICAN PEOPLE, AND
ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF ANYONE WHO
KNOWS ANYTHING ABOUT THE COUNTRY
WILL TELL YOU.
THE NATIONAL MURDER RATE IN
MEXICO WAS FIVE TIMES OURS,
SINCE 2006 MORE THAN 250,000, A
QUARTER MILLION PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
MURDERED IN MEXICO.
HUNDREDS OF POLITICIANS AND
JUDGES, THERE IS A WAR GOING ON
THERE.
IT IS SPREAD BY DRUG CARTELS
THAT REACH INTO THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF THE MEXICAN GOVERNMEN
GOVERNMENT, THAT IS NOT AN
EXAGGERATION.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
ENTIRE MEXICAN STATE RECENTLY
PLEADED GUILTY TO DRUG
TRAFFICKING CHARGES, THE
GOVERNOR ON A STATE TOOK BRIBES
TO LET CARTELS OPERATE FREELY,
WHICH THEY DID.
JUST THE OTHER DAY MEXICO'S
PREVIOUS PREVIOUS PRESIDENT WAS
CREDIBLY ACCUSED AT TRIAL," BY A
WITNESS TAKING $100 MILLION
BRIBE FROM AL TROPPO.
IN EFFECT, MEXICO IS BECOMING A
NARCO STATE, DOES NOT THOSE
STOMACH THE MOST VOLATILE
COUNTRY IN THE REGION, NICARAGUA
IS IN SEVERE TROUBLE.
EL SALVADOR ARE LARGELY
CONTROLLED BY GANGS, VENEZUELA
MEANWHILE IS LITERALLY FALLING
APART.
A RECENT BROOKINGS INSTITUTION
REPORT PREDICTED, A TOTAL
COLLAPSE OF VENEZUELA WHICH
COULD HAPPEN ANY DAY MIGHT
CREATE 8 MILLION REFUGEES, FREE
PERSPECTIVE THAT MORE REFUGEES
IN THE ENTIRE SYRIAN WAR.
THAT IS WHEN IT UPENDED ALL OF
EUROPE.
SOMETHING SIMILAR CAN EASILY
HAPPEN HERE, TO ARSENATE LIKELY
WILL.
AND YET, THE POSITION OF
DEMOCRATS AND THE CONGRESS IS
THAT EVERYTHING IS FINE AND YOU
ARE NET IF YOU DISAGREE.
NOTHING NEEDS TO BE DONE.
THAT IS THE DEFINITION OF
RECKLESS, IT DOES WORK MIKE
WORSE.
IT IS LIKE LETTING YOUR KIDS
PLAY IN TRAFFIC.
IT WOULD PREVENT THAT FROM
HAPPENING.
DEMOCRATS HAVE BECOME EXTREMISTS
ON THE QUESTION OF BORDERS, YOU
NEVER KNOW THAT FROM WATCHING
TELEVISION, THE MEDIA WON'T SAY
IT.
EVEN IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, SOME OFFICIALS
SEEM INTENT ON MAKING
NANCY PELOSI'S CASE FOR HER.
REPUBLICANS, THE REAL EXTREMISTS
HERE.
HERE'S WHAT WILBUR ROSS SAID
TODAY WHEN HE WAS ASKED ABOUT
WORKERS WHO AREN'T BEING PAID
DURING THE SHUTDOWN.
>> PEOPLE MIGHT HAVE TO PAY A
LITTLE BIT OF INTEREST.
THE IDEA IS THAT A CHECK FOR
ZERO IS NOT A VALID IDEA.
THERE HAVE BEEN ADS RUN BY
NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC SECTOR
CREDIT UNIONS, THOSE HAVE
ANNOUNCED VERY LOW INTEREST RATE
LOANS TO BRIDGE PEOPLE OVER THE
GAP.
>> Tucker: MORE DEBT?
MORE INTEREST PAYMENTS?
THAT IS A SOLUTION, NO IT DOES
NOT.
THOSE ARE THE LAST THINGS THAT
MOST AMERICAN STOMACH AMERICAN'S
NEEDS, THERE WAS AN IDIOTIC
THING TO SAY.
THEY KNOW A PROPAGANDA WHEN THEY
SEE ONE.
IT IS A SHAME AND IT IS ALSO A
DISTRACTION BECAUSE IT CHANGES
THE NATURE, THE FUNDAMENTAL
NATURE OF THIS COUNTRY.
OUR BORDERS REMAIN VULNERABLE
AND THE STAKES ARE HIGHER THAN
THEY'VE EVER BEEN ASKED OF THE
CHAOS JUST SOUTH OF THEM.
LEADERS WHO CARED ABOUT THIS